magnificent lifestyles with beautiful
cause big houses and standing on
rooftops I did wonder is there something
that I might be missing out on is there
maybe an easier way to make money
how many times do you watch or read
something online and just want to go
[ __ ] chitty-chitty that [ __ ] but
then again you don't really know all the
facts because I mean how could you know
everything and spending more time at
home and on the internet lately I'm sure
you can relate to this there's been so
much more [ __ ] shared on social
media over the past months that I've
blocked and unfriended more people that
I have during election time but in this
rise of self-proclaimed know-it-alls it
inspired a new idea to unearth BS and
I'm talking about both sides both sides
of an idea or belief for you to decide
which is [ __ ] this is a super
exciting adventure for me to help add
much-needed clarity to a very hazy space
right now I've decided to call the show
BS which could stand for [ __ ] it
could stand for both sides it doesn't
really matter I'd like to play on words
so that's what we're gonna call it this
show is brought to you by the one and
only Squarespace that all-in-one
platform to build awesome websites for
your work let's get into it this month
saw record high internet usage across
the globe with the top story being the
obvious coronavirus we've seen some
powerful people promote phony cures and
scientifically vague conspiracy theories
run while we've seen snitches whistling
stitches and wondered if Kim Jong hoon
is alive on our tears we spawned a doom
at the hat the legs of murder Hornets
and lost sleep at the insecurities of
future paychecks a fearsome feel and
others capitalize on what many people
like to call fake gurus
the Sun climb in purchasing online
courses to see more money foster to
probably get rich quick is what I'm
calling BS both sides on today I'm going
to be taking a one-on-one session with
self-help guru and millionaire Kevin
David and then right after that I'm
going to be doing an online session
one-on-one with UK's number one D
motivational speaker and someone who
calls people like Evan David absolutely
bullshitters entrepreneur and business
owner might win at both sides of one
idea which side would you find yourself
on everybody seeks guidance in the
journey towards success wealth health
and happiness where if you have all
three you've won historically we
levitate towards charismatic open-armed
mentors leaders willing to share their
experience and knowledge for our foggy
seeming betterment some are genuine
others well they merely exploit our
needs to be guided our desire to be
better and today the latter are called
fake gurus or contra panniers rewind a
few hundred years and they were called
snake oil salesmen however evolving a
name their product false hope and
methods deceptive marketing and
persuasion tactics remain the same the
big picture here is self-help a term
first coined by Samuel smiles in 1855
with the publishing of his book of the
same name promoting the idea of self
empowerment never-say-die approach to
life aimed at the realization of one
own potential and in 42 today the
movement explains that you can do it
whoever you are no matter what your
circumstance through a bunch of easy
steps because well what I have created
financially in my life is very simple
and that is why it will work for you now
a full-blown global industry on track to
be worth 13 billion dollars in the USA
alone how do we separate genuine
empathetic mentors true guidance from
the smoke and mirrors salesman that
extract our hard-earned cash and time
like predator to prey in the weakest of
moments one thing is for sure social
media a constant parade of carefully
constructed personas messaging others
succeeding in impressive contrast
multiplies the possibility for these
salesmen to exponentially not only in
its reach ability but in the way that
social media leaves more people feeling
inadequate than ever before it is that
inadequacy that self-help swoops into
phone Bennett's purveyors aren't ways
day to help
unfortunately so to kick off this
discussion with you I created a website
and ask the question in your opinion if
self-help gurus hope or hurt more people
out of 380 responses 42% said that they
hurt more people than they help 34% said
the opposite and 24% were on the fence
they were completely contradicting
answers like it promotes living fake
lives and in turn brings people down
with having unrealistic ideas of success
and then others saying that self-help
gurus actually hope ignites a spark and
thank you for having your say and thank
you to Squarespace for making this
possible I'm gonna tell you a bit more
about them now before we get into the
interviews I was super surprised that we
were able to set up our BS voting sites
so quickly which is really down to how
easy Squarespace makes it to get website
work done now these awesome templates
that are ready to go and actually look
pretty cool great for filmmakers on the
rise if I only knew about this earlier
I've spent so much time building each of
my websites from scratch but do you live
in you know so yeah head over to
Squarespace for a free trial and then
when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace calm /da mace to save 10% on
your first purchase of your website or
domain with a code dan mace now before
we get into this and I really want to
emphasize this I am taking no side here
this is for you to draw a conclusion and
I'm just highlighting both sides I'm
speaking to two different people on both
sides of the fence and letting them
speak openly and really share what they
believe I do obviously have my own
beliefs here but my work is very
different I look at myself like an
artist where I don't do the work that I
do to try and turn a fat profit at the
end of the day it's not all about making
money for me I get a lot of enjoyment
out of working hard and you know I truly
believe that hard work works but seeing
this climb I'm sure you have to on
Facebook and Instagram and YouTube
videos of these self-proclaimed
millionaires showcasing these
magnificent lifestyles with beautiful
cars big houses standing on rooftops I
did wonder is there something that I
might be missing out on is there maybe
an easier way to make money I've seen
YouTube videos titled how to make money
when you sleeping you know this may be a
real thing I don't know I I may be too
old for this this kind of thing so I let
the pros answer my questions I asked
each of them the exact same questions
two interviews two completely different
answers you be the judge you know really
I truly am just an average person I was
an accountant I was working 80 hours a
week and I just started right and I was
just trying things and I failed creating
an app I failed creating an affiliate
site I fail at all these things before
finally I found Amazon I found ecommerce
and then it works now I have software
companies now I have 80 people working
for me right and all of that started
from a tiny tiny little choice to just
get started and it just created this
chain reaction that you
fold into what it is now and so my
background was I sold my own business
and I had a working class like I
couldn't believe that I finally had a
lump sum of money in my bank account so
I wanted to go and find experts in this
field to give me genuine unbiased advice
and I couldn't find anybody and your
courses and would you you delivering
have you seen an increase in in this
time based on the the job security issue
oh yeah for sure I mean you know in
today's day and age people who are lucky
enough to subscribe to people like me
and people who are trying to help people
kind of get this information it's a
really important thing right but it's
kind of human nature to say oh that
sounds too good to be true right that
must be a scam right but now literally
quite literally you can press the right
key with on a keyboard and you can
completely change your life in a matter
of months like I've seen it happen with
my students I've seen it happen for
myself I'm in an FBI post moment I I'm
undercover in these courses right now
and I'm in facebook groups where we are
agreeing to give each other five star
reviews by the products and then refill
each other through paper
are we being taught to do the same every
single students bought their course what
it's a genuine success rate and I've got
stats that say it's not point two
percent so nor point two percent of
their actual students go on to achieve
what's claimed by the coop or else how
would some people live in mansions and
other people just be scraping by right
those people who have you know nice
things and more financial capability and
means they must know something that
other people don't and they're comparing
themselves to this lifestyle that these
gurus claim they have when the reality
is alum bows rented the house at the
film the videos and they actually they
crowdfunding's they iron out for a day
or they hire out for a weekend and the
old dorm same videos nothing comes in 90
days or 30 days or 60 days you're not
going to be financially free in any of
these areas unless you don't actually
make one equal thing that you're
teaching you're good at selling courses
that's what your skill is you're a good
marketer you're not an entrepreneur what
can I do right now
if
you know what I have is a basic intake
connection how can I start earning some
form of passive income sure so I mean
passive income right Gary fee likes to
talk about the fact that passive income
doesn't exist right he's wrong
it does exist there's so many ways right
I mean some of the popular ways that
people talk about a lot or dropshipping
I like to sell gadgets what you've been
Mansa clip-ins not i've been months to
be selling widgets pinners as a sideline
lines you need people to make pens need
people to work in the hospitals and not
before time
the world needs these people it's not a
bad thing why if you made thousands and
thousands of dollars would you then then
go and teach a thousand strangers
because that's what they are and to go
and do the very things that you do in
your market you're turning your
customers into passes and then there's
you know all forms of e-commerce Amazon
FBA
siphon Amazon FBA and I thought made any
money part knowledge is power I'm sure
you've heard that before so that's the
first thing
if someone's desperately trying to prove
to you how successful they are or how
they're not a scam I think that speaks
volumes and the potential for a massive
massive scale and skill if you
understand how to take advantage of it
always equates to money I've taken this
that one step further I wanted to almost
see how easy was it to create
credibility or authority in this area a
lot of them are Amazon best I went and
wrote a book in one hour a blank book at
a minute absolutely nothing in this book
and I got that to number one on Amazon I
even called it how to get a number one
Amazon bestseller it took me one hour
confidence is a learned skill like
anything else right and the best way to
be confident is to start saying that
you're confident right say you're
confident and then live and embody that
right it's high goods for our course and
it said he could make you win the PGA
Tour within 90 days and you've never
played a single round of golf before and
it used to be twelve thousand nine
hundred ninety seven dollars it was not
1997 dollars would you buy it
of course you [ __ ] wouldn't know the
most important part of all your opinion
if you are just a keyboard warrior
please made it out in the comments below
Tom your thoughts please let it go
what's your experience with self-help
gurus does it work doesn't it work is it
[ __ ] is it great and thank you so
much for watching this once a month to
show BS I hope you enjoy it let me know
in the comments - if you didn't enjoy it
and other than that don't forget your
awesome beer and I'll see you next week
with a normal block
[Music]